look at is the policy of the Biden
Administration to have open borders
period Joe Biden himself blurted It Out
3 days ago he said when they asked him
point blank is the border secure he said
no and I've said that for a number of
years well he needs to tell that to
secretary mayorcas plus Jean Miss Jean
Pier because that's the exact opposite
of what they have said notice what the
mayor of Chicago said he said this is
not sustainable we're going to run out
of money soon because we don't have the
money for the Social Services for this
influx of migrants and the answer is to
give them citizens ship H how is that
the answer uh when when secretary
blinkin uh met with the president of
Mexico in their joint communic he also
implied that the answer was somehow to
give this influx of Migrant citizenships
well we understand that would allow them
to vote perhaps that's the goal but I
don't see how that will solve the the
fiscal uh problem the the the fentol
problem the crime problem the fact that
these cities these counties these States
they're running out of money